عقوبات لا تحصى وحصار اقتصادي لم يخطر على
بالي اكثر الروس تشاؤما
ووراء كل حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه تضحيه جديده
الا ان المنطقه الرماديه التي اختارتها
الصين جعلت من العقوبات مجرد خطط لا تمثل
الواقع
بمرور اشهر الحرب حل الواقع مكان التفاؤل
اذ لم تنفذ صواريخ روسيا بل بالعكس تخطت
صناعتها ازمه الرقائق واشباه الموصلات ولم
يبقى امام النيتو الا الحل الاخير
تجفيف المنبع ومعاقبه الشركات الصينيه
الثقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين ستنهار
اذا فرضت بروكس العقوبات على شركات صينيه
بزعم انها تساعد روسيا اوروبا قد تدخل
حربا امريكيه بالوكاله وتضع على المحك
علاقتها باكبر شركائها الاقتصاديين تقول
لغه تهديد واضحه تزامنت مع سياسه اليد
الممدوده التي رفعها وزير الخارجيه الصيني
الذي يبدا جولته الاوروبيه من باريس و
برلين وهما اكثر الدول اعتدالا في
العلاقات مع بلاده
العقوبات لا تزال حبيسه المسوده الا ان
استهداف سبعا من شركات التكنولوجيا الابرز
قد يفتح الباب للمزيد من العقوبات
والعقوبات المضاده في الوقت الذي تستفيد
الصين من تداعيات الحرب بفاعليه
يبدو ان الخطوات الامريكيه كانت اسرع من
ماكرون الذي عاد من الصين وهو يتلو عبارات
الاستقلاليه الاوروبيه ما يفتح الباب امام
انقسام اوروبيين حول جدول دخول صراع مع
الصين خدمه للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه دليل
اخر واشنطن لم تنجح في فرض العقوبات على
الصين عبر مجموعه السبع وتجد صعوبه مماثله
في فرض حظر تجاري كامل على روسيا بعد ان
فشلت قبلها في اقناع فكين بالمفهوم الغربي
للحياد وهي التي منحت لشركاتها حريه
التعامل مع من تريد مقابل حصولها على
الكثير من النفط والغاز
المقومين باليوان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات